we have just got a reaction from the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt who's put out
this statement saying inflation is a
stealth tax that's the biggest threat to
living standards in a generation so we
support the bank's action today so we
succeed in halving inflation this year
that's one of Richardson's five pledges
that he set out at the beginning of the
year of course the chancellor goes on to
say we will play our part by making sure
that government decisions are in
lockstep with the bank's approach
including by resisting the urge right
now to fund additional spending or tax
cuts through borrowing which will only
add fuel to the inflation fire and
prolong the pain for everyone so Ed I
wonder what you make of the Chancellor's
response to that and also reminding us
perhaps of the circumstances in which
the chancellor took over after Liz
truss's rather short-lived time in
office
it's it's more or less in line with what
you would expect from the chancellor I
mean obviously
um after what happened last year uh the
treasury very keen to underline that
they are not uh they don't want to
undermine the bank they want to to give
the impression of kind of Harmony within
the kind of different authorities that
deal with monetary policy here
um However the fact that inflation is
coming down that's something that the
bank is mostly focused on remember it's
their job to try to keep inflation as
close as possible to two percent we're
still way above that at the moment still
around that kind of 10 level it is
expected to have Peak now and it's
coming down in the coming months but
still a long way from it the bank's
forecast as it gets down to around two
percent uh by the end of the kind of
forecast Horizon so that's in a couple
of years time but still quite a long way
for it to go so that cost of living
crisis you know we're all feeling it now
unfortunately those pressures on prices
and on wages as well are likely to be
quite high for quite some time